at this altitude I can run flat-out for
my hands hello my little kittens this is
Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show I'm
testing a new mic so if it sucks balls
please let me know on Twitter hashtag
suck balls otherwise if you like it
hashtag like balls I'm kidding don't do
that don't do either actually just
communicate with me like human on the
interwebs
instead of using hashtags thank you very
much the Tim bear show is typically
involved with deconstructing world-class
performers trying to identify the
routines the tips the books the
influences and so on that help you to
replicate the successes of people who
are the very best at what they do
whether they are hedge fund managers
actors and politicians like Governor
Schwarzenegger for instance musicians
like Mike Shinoda blah blah blah
everyone in between chess prodigies
we've got something for everybody now
every once in a while I do a Q&A format
where people will vote on questions
submit and up vote questions just like
you have in the past week or two so
several thousand people voted on
questions and I have the top 10 to 15
I'm gonna tackle as many as I can in the
next short stint the short period that
we have together before I have to run to
dinner so let me start at the beginning
but Before we jump into the questions I
want to recommend that you check out my
movie picks I watch a lot of movies and
I uncover some pretty fun ones because I
dig very deep and I search far and wide
for lots of weird esoteric stuff if you
go to 4-hour workweek calm I'll spell
that fo you Rho you are it's under a
4-hour workweek comm /v mio Vimeo is a
sponsor and I have been a member for
many years now if you go to 4-hour
workweek com /video you
and find some of the movies that have
been amazing for me inspiring game
changing or in some cases life-changing
there are some really really impressive
movies and before I've spoken about for
instance a science fiction short called
World of Tomorrow which was the winner
of the Grand Jury Prize at Sundance for
short films and is just a really
thought-provoking intense 16 minutes or
so I've mentioned waking up with sam
Harris which is actually a lecture and
effectively a class which is the perfect
tool if you want to explore mindfulness
and meditation and for those of you who
have listened to a lot of these podcasts
you know that perhaps 80% of the top
performers all have some type of
meditative practice and it can differ
whether that is say a DJ or founder of
The Glitch Mob all the way to source and
anger they all have some type of
mindfulness practice then you have the
act of killing which is probably the
most brutal innovative documentary I've
ever seen and many more so they they
have just about anything you can imagine
from documentaries on the revival of
manual work through motorcycles which is
super cool you can check that out a
breakdancing documentary and the one
that I want to highlight today is a very
short film called the lady in number six
and the lady in number six is an Oscar
winner
it is a short about Alice now Alice is a
hundred and nine years old and the
world's oldest pianist and Holocaust
survivor and this short film is really
mind expanding for me was mine expanding
for me in a number of respects it just
shows the importance of mental framing
and also how your perspective can lead
to happiness or resentment at any given
point in time and there are a number of
people in the film who appear besides
Alice and you can look at the their
demeanors and the contrast and
perspectives it's very very interesting
but 109 years old
very very sharp still moving around
playing the piano every day I found it a
really enlightening and engrossing
so it's only get 20 to 30 minutes long
so the the name again is the lady in
number 6 you can give 4 hour workweek
comm /v mio and i will be continuing to
add movies to this page they are not
affiliate links but I do have a discount
for you guys for any of the films that
you might watch so you can check that
out but the subtitle is listen to the
secrets for a long and happy life so the
lady in number 6 check it out it's short
well we're at the time go to 4-hour
workweek comm /video alright now moving
on let's get to the very first question
just jump into it and I think I'll spend
a good amount of time on this question
and I've mid a handful of those that
were voted up because I thought the
wording was weird or confusing so the
first one tackle is this question from
Mike and Santa Cruz they say blogging
1.0 is dead if you had to build an
audience from scratch today how would
you start well this is a tricky question
because I you may be tackling the wrong
problem and let me explain how I think
about this and just to put things in
perspective so I have a number of
platforms I obviously have the blog
which gets somewhere between I don't
know one and two million unique visitors
per month then I have my Twitter and
social Twitter alone gets I don't know
1.3 million or so in terms of followers
and then the podcast which is hundreds
of thousands per episode and so on and
so forth so I've tried it all right I've
played around with any platform you can
imagine and I live in Silicon Valley and
invest in tech here's my perspective so
I'll answer your question somewhat
directly and literally first there is
always a market for high-quality and
there's always a market for long-form ok
I'm gonna recommend a couple of
resources right off the bat there's
always a market for high-quality there's
a book called small Giants I would
recommend that you check out and this is
to say if you offer the best of anything
you can charge a premium and your
customers were 10 will tend to be very
high margin low headache customers so
you could say produce the best cigar in
the world or her even in the top 10
percent and charge hundreds or thousands
dollars per cigar you could do the same
thing with leather pants and sell them
and people like Sheryl Crow and only
make a couple of hundred or even fewer
per year and make hundreds of thousands
or millions of dollars per year that's
actually an example from small Giants
this is related to long form and that's
how I interpret blogging 1.0 is writing
blog posts and then having comments on
those posts there's always a market for
long form and people lament the death of
long-form the death of this the death of
that oh my god you know TV is going to
be the death of radio and podcasts are
going to be the death of this and this
is going to be the death of that and it
makes for very sensational headlines but
I think it's usually mostly hot air so
long form here's the advantage of
long-form content and I've always
specialized I think in long-form content
you look at my books they're not short
they're not intended for people who
claim to have short attention spans and
many of my blog posts are 15 pages long
20 30 pages long if you print them out
and the reason I approach it this way is
because if you're building an audience
and I'll come back to that aspect of
your question the the most labor
efficient way to build an audience over
time is to have evergreen content so I
write long pieces that will be more
valuable from an SEO real estate
standpoint two years from the date I
write it compared to the week it
launches if that makes sense
so were you to look at my back catalogue
and the stats I'm on WordPress VIP if
you were to look at my stats or Google
Analytics you would see that my most
popular posts that get hunt get get each
hundreds of thousands of visits per
month were written several years ago and
that's very much by design I'm not upset
by that because I fully expect that some
of the articles I write this year for
instance my post on practical thoughts
on suicide which is a very intense post
I expect that will continue to gather
steam and be spread around and shared
and a year from now it will be right in
the top ten ranking
which is very important to me so the
question you ask though has very is is a
multi-layered question and there are a
lot of assumptions built into it so if
you had to build an audience from
scratch today let's examine that why do
you have to build an audience at all now
the the belief right now is you have to
be on social you have to be putting out
content I think that's [ __ ] you
don't have to at all
Amazon didn't start with building an
audience uber didn't start with building
an audience so if your goal is to create
a profitable or massively scaled
business that may not be the right thing
to focus on that's that's part one part
two is I encourage you to always ask
yourself why three times when you feel
like you have to do something so you
have to build an audience ask three
times and this is something I think I
adopted from Accardo similar just
spelled with an R is a Brazilian
entrepreneur asking why three times so
why do you have to build an audience
well and you might say because I have to
have people to sell to when I launch my
product okay well why do you have to
launch your product well because I want
to build a business that allows me to
the freedom let's just say to travel the
world and have enough income to do a B
and C all right let's take travel the
world it may turn out once you ask why
three times that volunteering at a local
Embassy for your target country like
Sweden or someplace else is the shortest
path to getting to your objective not
building an audience so don't mistake
the intermediate signposts or an uneven
signpost the intermediate steps that
you've been told repeatedly are
important as the goal itself and this
this comes back to a lot of the
discussion in the 4-hour workweek about
multiple currencies and the fact that
income is only one currency of time you
have mobility and that the value of that
money is determined by the number of w's
you control in your life you know where
you live
what you do who you spend your time with
and so on and the reality that income is
a barter system you are taking this
paper or digital symbolism basically
these units and trading them for expiry
or possessions so there may be more
direct ways like volunteering like
taking a specific job any number of
things that could get you to your goal
faster than building an audience because
building an audience is quite frankly is
a pain in the ass it is it is not an
easy thing and it requires a very
concerted conscious and well-planned
effort okay a couple of other
recommendations if you still decide that
building an audience is the right step
or the right place to focus a couple of
things I would suggest read the article
1,000 true fans by Kevin Kelly this is
an important concept to grasp because
you do not want to target the mass the
masses your objective should not be to
build the largest audience possible it's
too vague it will be too expensive in
terms of cost per acquisition even if
that cost is measured in the man-hours
that you put into creating content the
least crowded channel is where you
should focus that's another reason why I
prefer long-form content the least
crowded channel is still long-form
content whether that is print or audio
and that is why I am able to compete
effectively for instance in the podcast
realm even though my podcasts are very
minimally produced I don't have a team
it's me and one freelance engineer and
my assistant that's it but I can compete
against podcasts that have many many T
many many people and groups of people
focused on producing a narrative
partially because I very in depth with
guests this this episode of course being
an exception I mean an anomaly a few
other points if you're trying to build
an audience the first place to start and
this is gonna sound funny is to look at
your credit card statement alright look
at your monthly credit card statements
and identify where you are price
incentives and price insensitive okay so
you could have a specific highlighter
for that let's just say they're printed
out use an orange highlighter red
whatever for things that you are price
insensitive about or you could spend
three or four times as much and not care
you should also break things into groups
where do you spend a hundred dollars a
year okay so obviously you're gonna have
to divide some things or multiply the
by 12 but what do you spend a hundred
dollars a year on what do you spend $250
a year on what do you spend $500 a year
on and what do you spend a thousand
dollars a year on and if you're in a
very high income bracket then you can
multiply those out obviously
okay that's step one and the price and
sensitive aspect is very important if
you want minimal headache from the
customers that you choose next you're
going to identify the subcultures that
you belong to what are the subcultures
you belong to are you a crossfitter are
you involved with orienteering are you
into role-playing games world of
warcraft
do you like particulars types of movie
are you into japanimation whatever it is
identify three to five subcultures that
you belong to you that you understand
very well and then for each of those
subcultures you're going to identify the
five sites that those people go to if
you had to guess where someone in that
subculture would go the five sites that
they go to regularly three to five the
three to five Twitter accounts they're
most likely to follow the three to five
Instagram accounts they're most likely
to follow the three to five Facebook
pages they're most likely to like or be
fans of the three to five podcasts that
they're likely to listen to and let's
just stop it there and you don't have to
do all of them but suspect that out and
what are you doing by following this
process what you're doing is defining
yourself your psychographics your
demographics and my first recommendation
is always going to be go after markets
that you belong to so when I launched
the 4-hour workweek my objective was
initially and the target is not the
potential market this is really
important to understand them the target
market is not your total market the
target market is the tip of the spear
that is what you use at the frontlines
to win the battle that then allows you
to win the war but you win the war when
your target demographic then expands to
include a lot of other people in
practical terms what does this mean when
I launched the 4-hour workweek my
objective was very measurable and what
gets measured gets managed as Peter
Drucker says I was going after
20,000 sales of the 4-hour workweek per
week - I think it was 20 to 35 year-old
tech-savvy males in New York in San
Francisco predominantly Chicago also and
this is because I did the homework
looking at Nielsen Bookscan I had a good
idea of what would be necessary to hit
the New York Times bestseller list I
knew what type of distribution I needed
hence the importance of Chicago and
having not only sales limited to the
coasts and I also knew that I belonged
to this 25 to 40 year old I said 25 to
40 year old tech savvy male demographic
therefore I knew how to appear
ubiquitous to these people in a
cost-effective way so follow me I knew
that if I were able to get on at the
time say Gizmodo TechCrunch Gawker
perhaps and a handful of other sites
then now Twitter was nascent in this day
and Instagram didn't exist but if I was
able to appear at say two or three or
four conferences that these people
attended I could appear as though I'm
spending millions of dollars or being
recruited by all these companies in
publications around the world when in
fact I only was targeting a handful in a
very concerted and surgical way okay
you're not trying to build the largest
audience possible you're trying to find
your 1,000 true fans so to bring it home
just review all this stuff you're trying
to find your 1,000 true fans who belong
to subcultures and markets you belong to
so that you can then design a product or
service that they will be price
insensitive to and in doing all of that
finding a handful of outlets or pages or
accounts that you can target so you can
very cost-effectively appear ubiquitous
in a surround sound way when you launch
something important to you and that is
it by focusing on the least crowded
channel you can we
at surprisingly low cost and with very
elegant surgical approaches and that is
a long answer to question number one so
I'm gonna go get a glass of water but
hopefully you guys find that useful and
I will be back ok I'm back you gorgeous
filthy animals and I'm going to do a
speed round at least to the extent that
I can do a speed round and jam through a
bunch of these questions here the next
question is from Mike M in Hoboken as
well as Holly Holly asked a very similar
question if you're the average of the 5
people you surround yourself with or
associate with most who are those 5
people for you this varies very widely
depends a lot on what my goals are and
I'm not purely pragmatic about my
friends either these need to be people I
enjoy hanging out with so it's not just
for furthering the goal of averaging out
to a higher standard but the first few
names that come to mind currently are
Kevin Rose Josh Waitzkin
so Kevin Rose entrepreneur cereal
founder has been on the podcast Josh
Waitzkin known as a chess prodigy the
inspiration for searching for bobby
fisher' has also been on this podcast
Garrett camp who's a co-founder of uber
phat co-founder of StumbleUpon etc I do
a lot of work with him but he is not on
the podcast it probably won't be because
he doesn't do as much PR as people like
me Jeffries or offski so jay-z has his
nickname Jeffery zorroski was a chef
featured in the 4-hour chef he was very
very helpful we did a lot of ridiculous
things in that book including the New
York City food marathon where we had
something like 26.2 dishes in 24 hours /
God knows how many different locations
and suppose right now 65 year old or
older 60 year plus let's just say 60 or
plus very fit dudes so older guys who
are in incredible shape who I have
trouble keeping up with really making a
study of their longevity and just
general life practices that lead to that
type of existence and then lastly I'd
say the the the Rick Rubin's of the
world so Rick Rubin legendary music
producer he was recently on the podcast
very Zen very calm
unflappable and I wouldn't say any of
those things come naturally to me so
that is the short answer to that
question next question this is from
Barry in Glasgow based on the self
experiments you conducted in your books
are there any habits you continue to
implement on a daily basis and I would
expand the experiments in the books -
also the blog and elsewhere and there
are plenty
there are tons that I continue to follow
whether that's using cold baths as well
as heat exposure to facilitate sleep
there was a piece that was put on the
blog with dr. Rhonda Patrick about using
saunas and heat for growth hormone
increase you can check that out
journaling in the morning I used the
five minute journal which was inspired
by the 4-hour workweek in fact the
people who created this read the book
and then created the 5 minute general so
that's a nice virtuous cycle but I used
the five minute journal typically in the
mornings although I try to do it at
night as well as a way to focus my day
the no complaint experiment that I wrote
about on the blog some time ago go
trying to go 21 days without complaining
and the parameters for that is something
that I'm experimenting with right now
and that involves wearing a bracelet
that can be swapped from wrist to wrist
the training program in effortless
superhuman in the 4-hour body is
something that I follow
generally on and off depending on on
what my goals are but if strength is the
goal and there's almost always a
component of that
the sex chapters those those get good
use hopefully more and more use but
those are in the 4-hour body the 4-hour
workweek I would say in certainly slow
carb the silicone I've been following
for something like 10 years now although
I'm in an Aikido genic experimentation
phase at the moment then you have the
4-hour workweek and I use stuff from all
of these books so many of the recipes in
the 4-hour chef sexytimes steak and so
on I use all the time 4-hour workweek
8020 principle and analysis automation
autoresponders all of that stuff is
implemented on a daily basis just had a
phone call with one of my right hands
yesterday going through and rank
ordering a bunch of things and what
we'll get to
some of that in a later question and in
fact we'll get to the next question
which is from Arturo in Mexico what is
the most important question you ask
yourself every day closely related to
the last question and I think that
question has to be which of these and
these are the items on my to-do list so
if you have a to-do list in front of you
which of these if done make the rest
easier or irrelevant this is something
that I've asked for many many years but
really looking for and I don't think I'm
the only person to call it this but
looking for the lead Domino so the the
the Domino at the front that once tipped
over will help make all the others
happen automatically make them all much
easier to do or make them irrelevant so
if you have multiple say revenue goals
and they're one that could have a
disproportionate ROI
for the number of hours invested then
that may make three or four other
revenue options irrelevant if that's
going to potentially comprise 80 percent
of what you would make from that entire
do list for instance so which of these
if done makes the rest easier or
irrelevant another question I asked a
lot is which of these makes me the most
uncomfortable and it's hard to define
important I know this this it can get
very complex very quickly trying to
define what is most important and I
won't spend time talking about that term
right now but instead of trying to
define certain terms you can just ignore
them or leave them out and that solves a
lot of problems and we talked about sort
of the the trouble of the word success
in the 4-hour workweek for instance but
you can ask which of these makes me the
most uncomfortable and that from an
80/20 analysis if done is going to
reduce anxiety and improve quality of
life the greatest potentially and that
often correlates to what you would
consider important so if you don't know
what the most important thing is to do
on your to-do list find the one find the
item that makes you the most
uncomfortable and that's probably it
next question if you could make one
thing mandatory in the nationwide high
school curriculum what would it be this
is a
also from Mike in Santa Cruz is pretty
good voting on his questions uh so this
is a potentially long conversation but
the first one may be somewhat unexpected
and that is mandatory sports to keep
kids occupied and focused and improving
themselves from 3 to 6 p.m. that's known
as the danger zone for after-school
programs when kids have idle hands from
3 to 6 often before their parents get
off of work that's when a lot of kids go
off the rails so I think mandatory
sports which I had in high school
starting in sophomore year I just
thought it was it was very powerful as a
tool alright next question this is from
Jerry a and Philadelphia Bruce Lee said
the six quote the successful warrior is
the average man with laser-like focus
and quote what methods do you practice
to maintain focus and follow-through to
achieve your goals rather than getting
sidetracked distracted or discouraged
first point then I'll make an answer to
that is that I do get sidetracked
distracted and discouraged there is a
post I wrote called I think it's
productivity hacks for the neurotic
manic-depressive and crazy and then in
parentheses like me so if you just
search productivity hacks for the
neurotic and then my name it will pop
right up just to give you an accurate
picture of what my days and weeks look
like so number one don't expect that
you're going to eliminate that stuff
hundred percent that's setting yourself
up for failure or feeling like a failure
you're going to get sidetracked
distracted and discouraged the question
is what can you do to minimize that or
more importantly because the goal isn't
minimizing getting sidetracked the goal
is getting really big things done or
getting things done they have outsized
returns and results right so there are a
couple of things that I find very
helpful
number one is a Chrome extension called
momentum this will prevent you from
getting lost on the Internet display is
a beautiful photo with a quote and then
your most important task for the day we
already talked about important so I
won't belabor it but the momentum
extension for Chrome check it out the
next is thinking of my day as split in
two maker period and manage your period
and there's a great essay by Paul Graham
called I think it's just the makers
schedule versus the managers schedule
some
that up until about lunchtime or early
afternoon I try to produce content and
focus on writing or recording audio
answer questions like this for instance
and then after lunch where my brain is
typically dialed down in terms of rpms
after eating anyway I try to focus on
the administrative stuff the managing
the conference calls the making the
trains run on time stuff and then the
five-minute journal I already mentioned
that helps me to keep somewhat focused
and the follow-through is related to
that since you do a recap and a
post-mortem on your day every evening
for a few minutes next question scooter
from silly Valley I don't know if that
is a real place but I kind of like the
name silly Valley question with all the
misleading information on health out
there what are the best or most reliable
resources this is very tough question
what I would say is and Richard Fineman
would say physicist here of mine I the
most important thing is not to trick
yourself and you are the most you are
the easiest person or not to fool
yourself and you are the the easiest
person to fool something along those
lines there's a book called bad science
that you should read bad science is
written by an MD named Ben Goldacre and
it teaches you how to parse good science
from bad science and to learn how to
evaluate headlines in the news that are
usually sensationalist or written by
people who don't understand how to read
studies properly and perhaps a bit of
both and I did take some excerpts from
that and created a appendix or I should
say bonus chapter in the 4-hour body
that goes through a lot of this so you
can check that out too if you have a
copy of the book condensed a lot of that
at the back of the 4-hour body but you
need to educate yourself so you can
separate fact from fiction good signs
for bad science good studies from bad
studies etc and it doesn't take that
long you can in an afternoon for most
people double your ability to be
intelligent about evaluating all of the
stuff that gets thrown at you mostly
noise very rare signal but that is that
alright let's see
next question I'm gonna answer is what
are your top 10 natural supplements that
you found most helpful and I want to
answer this question because I am of the
mind now that you want to minimize
supplementation because supplements
should be supplements unless you have a
clear deficiency that you cannot fix
through diet you should attempt to fix
it through diet optimize through diet
and there are a couple of easy ways to
do that I like to so there are foods
that I consume regularly for instance I
mean coconut oil Brazil nuts etc I try
to consume a diet that includes a
spectrum of colors so I often order food
or get for instance materials from a
salad bar based on getting as wide a
spectrum of different colors as possible
I think that allows you it helps you to
cover a lot of bases and then the last
there's a supplement I use I've used it
for years talked about it before our
body athletic greens which is kind of my
insurance policy to cover things that I
don't hit but there I would never take
ten supplements and natural is really a
dicey distinction or description because
natural does not mean good does not mean
safe Hemlock is natural it'll kill you
natural and synthetic are not always
great distinctions but whole food
supplements supplements derived from
whole food I think are generally all
things equal which they never are better
than synthetic but and also if you're
doing something like recombinant human
growth hormone right you want human
growth hormone that's been synthesized
and not pulled out of cadavers there are
more dangers with the latter than the
former so that is a long way of saying I
don't use I try not to use any
supplements all the time because you
develop tolerances there are feedback
mechanisms that can screw up your own
endogenous or sort of
production in your own body by over
supplementation so I'm trying to go
Whole Foods whenever possible athletic
greens when I feel like I'm probably not
covering my bases are traveling a lot
next question
from Chase in Kentucky and his question
is what are the things you've done to
become a better writer
I still don't I'm not satisfied with
myself as a writer I think I am a better
teacher than I am a writer so that has a
lot to do with how I format the
sequencing of things in my books and
simplification of things but a couple of
things number one is read outside of
your genre so even if you're a
nonfiction writer read good fiction
don't become a bigot genre wise a couple
of books I found very helpful on writing
my Stephen King's simple and direct on
writing well by I can never pronounce
his last name I thinks Williams is in
stir on the psychological game of
writing and just actually getting past
your own head and insecurities to write
I think that bird by bird is one of the
best books out there if you can't find a
professor or someone who is a a writer
per se to proof or review your writing
then find a lawyer find a lawyer to look
at your stuff even if they're not a good
writer so to speak or don't consider
themselves such they're very good at
removing extraneous words or nebulous
words so that that is a tip and then get
into the practice of writing so I use
morning pages you can use any number of
different types of journal so if you
just search what my morning journal
looks like and then my name what my
morning journal looks like in my name
you'll see examples of how I do that and
the the specific journal that I use just
to get into the habit of writing for
yourself they are not intended for
publication and then when I am having my
material proof read by people my general
rule is if one person loves something it
stays in so I only need a vote of one to
keep something but if one person hates
something that's not enough to get rid
of it so I need a consensus to remove
something
but I only need one person to love
something for me to keep it in or to
strongly strongly consider keeping it in
and that is that for now I'm sure there
are other things but those are the ones
come to mind next question this is a
proposal idea alright from Kentucky we
all have times when we need a brain dump
what are your guilty pleasures for those
times when your brain needs a rest so I
think of brain dump is just getting a
lot out of your head in a brainstorming
session without editing but let's assume
I'm answering the second part which is
when my brain needs a rest what do I do
I like hand drumming I have gem Bay's
which is DJ embe I have a hand pan which
is kind of like a steel drum turned
inside out I also watch serial
television but it's it's not appointment
viewing I'm downloading say true
detective or something like that and
then watching each episode the jinx also
it's just coincidence that both those
are very very dark the something a
little lighter I read fiction and I
actually really like reading kids books
or young adult books because I think the
books that are really well-written and
stand the test of time in the young
adult category are just well written
books don't have a lot of extraneous
[ __ ] or you know $10 words when a 10
cent word will suffice
and I think they're just very well
written wrinkle in time is one that was
gifted to me not too long ago and
recently read that and just loved it it
was a really fun read and very relaxing
to read before bed to turn off the
problem-solving apparatus in my own mind
so that is my answer for the brain dump
taking a rest those are a few things
that I find very helpful and then there
are a bunch of questions here I'm just
gonna answer one more and then get going
and let you guys get back to your day so
please you can charge forth and conquer
worlds last question from Jamie this is
uh oh boy galoshes da UK Gloucester I
don't know how to pronounce it GL o u c
EST ER it's like worse desire sauce
Worcester sauce I can't ever print out
damn words in any case what would you go
back and tell your younger self I've
thought about this a lot my answer for a
long time was you know nothing I
wouldn't change anything because these
these questions are related what would
you change if you could go back to age
20 or 25 what would you do differently
they're closely related the only thing
that I've been able to think of and this
is only very recently that I realized
this is start meditating I think that I
would recommend to myself that I start
meditating earlier I've talked about
this quite a lot and in 80 plus percent
of the people I interview for the
podcast who are all world-class
performers best of the best have some
type of meditative practice and there
are some very good books related to that
wherever you go there you are I think it
is Jon kabat-zinn there's also a book
called radical acceptance by Tara brach
that I like a lot br ACH that's that
covers more than just meditation and
then last but not least I should say I
practice Transcendental Meditation and
Vipassana meditation but there many
different types transit TM
Transcendental Meditation is just TM no
org you can find info there there's
things I dislike about it I think it
should be much less expensive to get
training but that's what I needed
ie someone to hold me accountable to get
into it other things apps like headspace
and calm very very good for getting
started and do less than you think you
can do for meditation this is key for a
lot of behavioural change but if you
think you can sit for 10 minutes do it
for five give yourself a margin for
error and for frustration so if you
think you can do 15s great do 10 but do
what will allow you to win in the
beginning the habit is more important
than hitting home runs every day in the
beginning and then last I will say check
out waking up this is the the lecture by
Sam Harris who is is is just an
incredible human being PhD in
neuroscience friend of mine he's also on
the podcast and waking up is an
outstanding introduction and and
collection of instruction really related
to meditation
so sort of a guide to spirituality
without religion as his subtitle but
waking up is a great video you can check
it out as I mentioned at the very
beginning at 4 hour workweek dot-com /a
Vimeo all spelled out for our workweek
dot-com /v mio and in terms of that
brain dump and relaxing you can also
find other things that i've watched
before bed or on the weekends to chill
out like the greasy hands preachers
they're all there shake the dust valley
uprising world of tomorrow maiden trip
etc active killing not so relaxing but a
fantastic documentary nonetheless the
most brutal thing probably you will ever
watch in your life so those are my picks
i'll be adding to this over time so
check that out at 4-hour workweek calm
/in vimeo and for those of you who are
listening if you have a company or
product or brand and you're interested
in sponsoring this podcast then i would
like to hear from you because i'm gonna
be doing a lot of really fun stuff
coming up soon just go to 4-hour
workweek all spelled out for our
workweek comm forward slash sponsor and
there's a short form fill it out and i
or my team will check it out soon so
please let me know 4-hour work week
comport saipan sir that is it have a
wonderful day evening week month life
until i speak to you next time
thanks for listening and kia kaha keep
it real
you